grab your sword and prepare to battle
Game of Thrones fans because we have a
new teaser which doesn't give away an
awful lot but is filled with some
interesting tidbits the most important
of which is that the actual trailer is
likely imminent if the season 7 teaser
is any indication we'll have two months
to wait for the official trailer or they
may go guns a-blazing and wait to air it
during the Superbowl
so take a minute and sit on your Thrones
as we analyze some of the goodies with
in the teaser starts with the whistling
winds of winter overtaking a wooden
carving of a dire wolf the animal of
House Stark you'll see this entire
trailer takes place in the war room of
Dragonstone the same place both Stannis
and Daenerys conducted their strategies
to win back the Iron Throne this time
however the threat isn't so much rival
houses but the White Walkers you can
even make out the pawn of the unsullied
being overtaken in the background winter
continues to creep even over the carving
of a dragon now it's unsure if this
represents one of Daenerys dragons being
taken down or perhaps the one that was
brought back from the dead near the end
of season 7 either way it does not bode
well for Daenerys and Jon Snow at the
opposite end of the war map we catch
glimpses of other pawns scattered along
the battlefield before flames erupt and
envelop the lion the symbol of House
Lannister
the teaser hints that the forces of the
north will be pushed south by the White
Walkers eventually culminating in a
giant battle somewhere in the middle by
my estimation and by the look at the map
this will occur at a location called the
neck a strategic choke point controlled
by the formidable but usually empty
ruined castle of moat Cailin it's
comprised mainly of swampland and is the
southernmost part of the north on the
border of the Riverlands but this would
also be one of the most ironic places to
stage a battle since the history of the
neck is one in which the children of the
forest the creators of the White Walkers
failed to defeat the first men they
invoked a magic called the hammer of the
waters which was an attempt to split
Westeros in half cutting off the first
men from venturing further but their
magic failed and the devastation caused
a large swampland instead it would also
be terribly ironic if Dragonstone the
thing that gave birth to the white
Walker was also the thing that became
its destruction
this time however we have a different
battle the
walkers versus all of Westeros and
instead of invoking the hammer of the
waters
it looks like obsidian dragonglass will
come into play here how exactly it
explodes like this may just be a
metaphor for the impending clash or
perhaps a new magic we don't know but
remember that season seven ended with
Daenerys allowing Jon Snow to mind the
dragon glass underneath Castle
Dragonstone in the teaser the clash of
Fire and Ice creates this giant new wall
of dragonglass which the White Walkers
wouldn't be able to penetrate is this
just history repeating itself walling
off the White Walkers until they managed
to get over it again we'll just have to
stay tuned to find out hey if you liked
this video make sure to give it a like
I'm planning to do detail breakdowns of
the next season of Game of Thrones and
I'm currently doing George RR Martin's
night fliers so make sure to check those
out and subscribe thanks for tuning in